in our own lifetimes the status of being
an MP has changed changed from something
that was a an asset on your CV to
something that arguably is is um is
something you have to
um excuse yourself for rather as if you
have on your record you know
police report having exposed yourself in
public
it's something like that and um I think
that's a shame I think we should have
good legislators I think we should have
the best I think the best people should
apply they're clearly not
and um and one way to solve that is is
to pay what MPS we have better I mean
there's no reason why a diversity
officer in the NHS should be being paid
twice as much as an MP I I think it's
Madness